[Music]
today's question comes from melissa in
alabama i'm 35 years old i've worked at
a major corporation for 10 years and
advanced my career to a very comfortable
financial spot however this role has
been physically and mentally draining
since covet
i'm grateful for the job and the
benefits however i'm extremely unhappy
my husband is also starting up a side
hustle and i'm building my own business
doing something that fills my cup we are
selling a rental home and i plan on
taking a 12 month sabbatical from my job
to build our businesses we would rely on
the profit from the rental sale to
offset my income should we be investing
the sale proceeds
instead of using them this way or does
happiness and quality of life outweigh
investing
well
brother the way this question is set up
it's almost impossible for drama queen
question
does happiness matter yeah no come on
the baby steps in the financial plan
that we teach at ramsey solutions is
what matters so assuming
the sabbatical means you can return to
the job in 12 months and that you do
regardless of how much you grow this
business and you don't go backwards in
the financial plan that we teach the
baby steps then sure but there's so much
in here that's unknown and up for
opinion and up for emotion um it's
really really hard to delineate an
answer there with all that's being
presented but don't go backwards not not
for me it's not i can i can cut right
through this crap
um
the um
here's the deal
when you you were doing just fine until
you couch it at the end
uh does happiness and quality of life
outweigh investing that they're not
mutually exclusive kiddo you can
actually do both
and so here's the thing
you are just sick and tired of this job
well so suck it up for until you can get
your side hustle up and running
you keep working until you get your side
hustle up and running
you get it up and running when you get
it up and running and get some money
coming in then you can afford to quit
you quit
but you don't burn off the rental
property
on a on the false doctrine the fight the
fatalistic premise that somehow you have
to trade money for happiness that's
absolute horse crap
okay you're just pissed off you're
you're scared you're tired whatever's
going on over this place you're working
and you do need to exit that place but
you need to tap the brakes and exit it a
little bit slower and get your dadgum
side hustle up and running and um but
you just you just put too much drama on
here you just really did uh you're not
gonna die
nothing's nobody's trying to kill you
you're okay
you just don't like it anymore you've
been there 10 years and suddenly you
have to hit eject and shoot into the
stratosphere just calm down a little bit
get your side hustle going use all of
the dissatisfaction that you have as
fuel for your energy to work a lot of
extra hours on this side hustle work
like a maniac for six to 12 months get
that side hustle money coming in and uh
then
uh then you can quit and you don't have
to sell the rental to pull that off
that's just if you want to sell the
rental it's fine but don't sell the
rental and then burn the money at the
altar of happiness that's absolute bs
it's overplayed sorry
i've been in situations where i'm
disgusted too and it took me a while to
dig out of the manure but it takes a
while to shovel when there's a full
truckload of it so just shovel kid
shovel you'll be all right
god i'm getting old and angry it's just
just grouchy
no i just crashed i don't disagree with
what you're saying i think there's
there's so much more i'd love to know on
this particular question and you're kind
of yeah but i agree with what you're
saying that's definitely an option i
just don't want to see somebody go
backwards financially because they want
to throw the side hustle faster there's
no reason to there's no reason it's not
and the side hustle is unproven oh well
yeah we don't even know what it is i
mean my goodness would 12 months even
grow it just what about me
yeah
yeah
so guarantee that a 12-month sabbatical
gets the business where you want it to
there's no guarantee the business ever
gets there exactly so that's why there's
a
very interesting question yeah yeah but
it's just
what happens is
that people there they build up we all
do this
but it requires some adult
maturity to work our way past it i'd do
it too sure no different than her i'm a
drama queen too
and so
you you build up this apex this
frustration and it reaches a boiling
point and then when you hit that top a
switch flips
and you're just ready to do anything you
get away from it
you just like you know it was a slow
climb to get there but once you're there
it's like
whatever it takes i got to get away from
this situation because this situation is
driving me bananas and unless you're in
danger yes
you know or or there's an ethics problem
or i mean something extreme you know all
it is is just frustration reached a
boiling point yes i agree and i do it
all the time i do too i i you know i go
along go along go along go along go
along go along and then all of a sudden
i'm done yes
and i have to stop and go wait a minute
that didn't happen suddenly that's right
that's in my head i loved your analogy
of the eject button that's really that's
really strong because it's like we only
hit eject when death is certain if we
don't get out right or extreme financial
harm is what you're pointing and so
sometimes we feel eject but it's not
really eject